uh
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and the
other day someone asked me like hey i
know you probably get this a lot but
what's the best phone out there right
now just the top dog just recommend one
and i just said galaxy s7 you know i
usually have a top phone that i can just
recommend to everyone nexus isn't for
everyone specs aren't for everyone but
you know galaxy s7 edge it's the go-to
right great screen great camera great
battery life it's fast some fun features
mixed in there i can't really go wrong
so yeah i recommend that but now galaxy
note 7 has just been announced and it's
coming out on august 19th and as we
expected note 7 is not super different
from the galaxy s7 edge we already have
in fact you could probably call it like
a galaxy s7 edge plus and from the first
impression this is everything that was
already great about the galaxy s7 and
then even better so that's a good thing
now first of all just to get it out the
way what happened to the note 6 i don't
really know but with the edge this is
technically the seventh note plus it
just kind of lines up better with the
galaxy s7 so this phone takes all that's
great about the galaxy s7 edge
and adds all that's great about the note
series so from the s7 edge you have your
great specs you have the snapdragon 820
four gigabytes of ram you know no six
gigabytes but whatever you basically
have your gold standard here at this
point
and you get your dual edge display but
adjusted a bit basically they moved the
apex of the curve a little bit closer to
the edges so there's more flat glass at
the front and just a small curve on the
sides but that subtle curve really
pushes the side bezel to almost nothing
as you can see like this is something we
were dreaming about five years ago and
now we have this basically nearly
bezel-less phone on the sides and they
curve the glass on the back the same way
too so the phone is symmetrical in shape
in the hand and it feels really good
plus it's all these premium materials
still as well the glass with the metal
rails all somewhere a little bit smaller
than the last note but also a little bit
bigger than the s7 edge but yeah overall
very familiar you also get the same
exact camera from the galaxy s7 the 12
megapixel f 1.7 shooter with optical
image stabilization and super quick auto
focus that's all still good and i'm not
even mad that it's not a new camera this
one is already extremely good at both
photos and videos and it might already
be the best low light shooter in any
smartphone so i'll take that
and then you get the expandable micro sd
card storage up to 256 gigabytes that's
also from the galaxy s7 and it's also
now fully ip68 waterproof like the
galaxy s7 and even the stylus is
waterproof too so no need to worry about
dropping it in water or even using it in
the rain or anything like that now from
the note line of course you bring in the
bigger size so the bigger display it's
now your 5.7 inch quad hd samsung super
amoled display and from first
impressions it's super lit
and you get the larger battery as well
it's a 3 500 milliamp hour battery in
this bigger phone and then it wouldn't
be a note without all the added s pen
features so of course the s pen is
improved again this year like i said
it's also waterproof
and now it's even more sensitive and has
a couple new features my favorite just
from the time i played around with it is
the gif capture which literally just
lets you
screen capture any portion of your
screen quickly and save it immediately
as a gif gif
gif it's super convenient and it might
be the most underrated feature that
nobody's talking about i haven't always
been a big stylus guy honestly i usually
try to give it a chance at first but
then gradually use it less and less but
when they add convenience features like
this it makes me want to give it another
shot also i almost tried to stick the s
pen in reverse just to see if it would
get stuck again
but
no i'm going to let someone else try
that anyway so you have this
frankenstein combination of the two best
phones samsung makes plus a couple of
extra features on top fast wireless
charging is still here and it works with
this sort of a moto mod like accessory
where you snap on a battery back on the
back of the phone and it wireless
charges so it doesn't even need any pins
another thing is they finally switched
over to usb type-c so this is the first
usb-c phone samsung has ever made still
has fast charging it might be a sign of
them starting to shift over all their
flagships to usbc in the future
and they even tossed in iris scanning as
a security feature now believe me i was
definitely skeptical about this like
when they said it on stage but they let
us try it and it seemed pretty damn cool
so you hold your phone up about a foot
from your face maybe a little less and
you just look at the phone to unlock it
it takes a couple seconds to set up and
then it seemed like each unlock got a
little bit quicker one after the next
like it was learning my eyes better and
after a while it was unlocking almost as
fast as the already really good
fingerprint sensor so it can seem like a
gimmick at first but it's good to know
at least it's a good gimmick it's not a
crappy trash feature it actually works
pretty well they have an entirely
separate ir sensor on the front of the
phone for this so it's not using the
front-facing camera and since it's
infrared it can work at night it can
work through sunglasses and apparently
it can't be tricked with a picture of
you apparently i'm definitely going to
try that though so overall the galaxy
note 7 looks like it has a lot going for
it i think the stealthy black version
might be my next phone honestly looking
at it of course there's also the new
blue one with the gold sides looks
pretty cool and then there's the silver
and gold phones naturally as well but
there's something about a stealthy all
black phone that draws me the software
experience is tuned up a bit again as
you would expect and obviously it's not
like their skin is going anywhere
they've been consistent with this
samsung bright white and colorful ux
over the past couple years but it's you
know it's better than it used to be i
don't know i guess i'm a fan so far from
the first impression so definitely stay
tuned for the full review so we can
figure out if this guy is worth the
premium price tag it's going to be going
for so make sure you subscribe to see
that if you haven't already and that's
basically been it that's the first
impression thanks for watching guys and
i'll catch you in the next one peace